while raya and the last dragon is a
crowd-pleasing film for viewers of all
ages there are some parts of the film
that younger viewers may miss
from romantic subtext to religious
parallels
here are the things only adults notice
in raya and the last dragon
as raya and the last dragon opens we see
raya riding her giant roly-poly
companion tuk-tuk through a barren
wasteland dotted with human statues
as we learn 500 years before the events
of the movie
dragons and humans lived together
peacefully in a paradise called kumandra
but their harmonious way of life was
destroyed when malevolent spirits called
the droon
invaded turning everyone they touched to
stone the dragons fought to protect the
humans and finally prevailed over the
drone
but all of the dragons were turned to
stone in the process save the last one
sisu who disappeared it's a beautiful
story but adult viewers are going to
realize that it seems to have glossed
over a few
important parts while raya presents
kumandra as paradise and its people
living in perfect
harmony sisu later explains that the
droon were born of human discord
if that's the case then kumandra must
not have been the idyllic
conflict-free world that ryan made it
out to be
adults will probably not miss that the
story of the dragons that riot tells at
the beginning of raya in the last dragon
holds a lot of parallels to a religious
creation story
rya's story begins with humanity living
in an idyllic world
watched over by benevolent magical
creatures who served as the source of
water and
rain and thus all life it is even
implied that the humans worshipped the
dragons in the reverent way they bow and
raise their hands to their foreheads
whenever they're in their presence
when the droon arrive it's the dragons
who sacrifice themselves in order to
give humanity another chance
and dragons who ultimately return
centuries later to restore the world to
its former glory
even during the 500 years that dragons
are gone human civilization
and conflict all centers around vying
for the favor they perceive as being
bestowed by the last bit of dragon magic
kids will likely take it all at face
value but for many adults the religious
parallels will be too strong to miss
when raya and namari first meet as
children the two instantly bond over
their shared interest in dragons later
in the film namari acts as an antagonist
until raya realizes that the key to
defeating the drone is trust and
literally puts her fate into mari's
hands by giving her heart's peace of the
dragongem
it's a moving arc for both characters
and could hold additional significance
from a certain point of view some adult
viewers may notice that while ryan never
gets an explicit love interest in the
film her relationship with nomare hits
many of the same beats often reserved
for romantic relationships
the way they meet closely mirrors anna
and han's first encounter in frozen when
hans is explicitly set up as on his love
interest
and their interactions throughout the
film can easily be interpreted as
flirtatious
even raya's voice actor kelly marie tran
sees their relationship
as being potentially romantic she shared
in an interview with vanity fair that
while disney's official stance says
nothing about ryan's romantic
inclinations
i think if you're a person watching this
movie and you see representation in a
way that feels really real and authentic
to you then it is real and authentic
when the terrifying drones show up in
kumandra they take the form of smoky
monsters giving off an ominous purple
glow that overtakes people and turns
them into stone
yet for most of the people that jiren
transforms into statues they don't
freeze in the position they were in when
the drone first wrapped around them
rather most of the time the statues end
up standing with their hands cupped in
front of them as if offering up an
invisible gift to a recipient only they
can see
while the position of the people
affected by the drone is never
explicitly addressed in the film
their cupped hands are actually a subtle
way of foreshadowing the eventual
solution that will be found by raya and
her friends
not only does the cupping motion hint at
the involvement of sisu
a water dragon but it also seems to
indicate an action of offering up
something
important to someone else this is what
raya eventually realizes she has to do
putting her trust in the mari and giving
her the heart tribes fragment of the
dragon gem
this is also what the dragons did 500
years before when they gave the gem to
sisu in the first place
it turns out that the only way to defeat
the drone is with an act of unity and
trust which the drone was subtly telling
its victims all along
in the story raya tells of the history
of kumandra after sisu sacrificed
herself the surviving human tribes went
to war with one another over possession
of the dragon gem which held the last
remnants of dragon magic
however at some point along the way
someone had to have noticed that sisu's
body was missing
unlike the rest of the dragons who had
been turned to stone sisu just vanished
what's more
somehow a legend began that sisu had
been washed away down the river
and that her body lay at one of its many
ends this is the story nemari tells raya
early in the movie which turns out to be
true since it leads raya to find sisu
six years later and yet even though none
of these stories would have existed
without someone having an idea about
cesu's fate and making a record of it
it appears that no one ever thought to
go looking for the heroic dragon
even while all of the tribes of kumandra
were at each other's throats over the
final scrap of dragon magic it didn't
seem to occur to anyone to seek out the
real live dragon that was very much
within reach
it seems bizarre that raya was the first
to go searching for sisu but every
indication points to the conclusion that
she was
kids may not think to ask why but adults
will likely wonder what kept anyone else
from seeking out sisu's resting place
after raya locates sisu she is
understandably wary of letting anyone
find out that her travel companion is a
real live dragon
even after making friends with young
boon and the formidable tong she is
reluctant to let either of them know her
friend's true nature
and yet for some reason early in the
film raya doesn't hesitate before
telling namari that she's found the
dragon sisu
unlike boone and tong who understandably
don't think twice about a human named
sisu
raya introduces her to namari in direct
response to namari's question about
whether raya was looking for the dragon
if anyone was going to realize that
raya's human friend sisu was actually a
dragon in disguise it should have been
namari
that she doesn't is lucky for raya but
you have to wonder why raya risked her
realizing the truth in the first place
during raya's visit to talon tribe to
locate their piece of the dragon gem she
comes across a seemingly abandoned baby
only to realize the baby is a con artist
really a con baby despite their
dishonest beginnings the baby and her
monkey-like companions throw in their
lot with raya
and wind up being indispensable in the
adventure that follows
eventually we learn that the baby's name
is noy and it quickly becomes clear that
she's uniquely precocious
able to both move and think on the level
of someone many times her age
but while noy mostly serves to provide
comic relief
adults will likely realize the profound
tragedy of a baby who has had to learn
the skills of someone
much older and fend for herself because
she lost her entire family
in the real world such a child would
have likely perished if they weren't
taken in by an older caretaker the
option to be adopted by a trio of
benevolent sticky-fingered primates
wouldn't really exist
in raya and the last dragon's fantasy
world noy is able to forge a new path
for herself as a street smart trickster
and thief but
adults won't be able to ignore the deep
sadness of a small child forced to grow
up too fast because if she didn't take
care of herself
no one would numerous times throughout
raya and the last dragon characters
question rya's quest to collect the
fragments of the broken dragon gem
she's always elusive in her answers not
wanting to give away the secret that
she's located sisu the last dragon
and is trying to reassemble the gem in
order to defeat the droon and bring back
all the people they've locked in stone
raya's fear is that after centuries of
conflict the other tribes would probably
short-sightedly attempt to seize sisu's
power for themselves rather than work
together for the betterment of all
however while raya's reluctance to
reveal the nature of her quest to anyone
else is
understandable why is she the only one
hunting gem pieces in the first place
after all the catalyst for all of the
conflict is that each of the tribes
wanted the original
dragon gem for themselves and that after
it was broken they all took whatever
they could get in the hopes of claiming
some of its power
rather than everyone wondering why raya
is collecting gem pieces
isn't the bigger question why no one
else is it seems that rather than being
mystified by her actions the other tribe
leaders should assume that raya's goal
is to amass more power for the heart
tribe
kids will likely take the constant
questions about ray's motivations in
stride but adults will wonder why no one
else thought to do the exact same thing
at the end of raya and the last dragon
after all of the last representatives of
each of the five tribes have given their
dragon gem pieces to namari their
combined trust and cooperativeness
revives the dragon gem which in turn
erupts with magic
wipes out the drone and revives all of
the people and dragons who have been
turned to stone
raya and her companions are reunited
with their lost loved ones and kumandra
is once again restored to the paradise
it once was
except it may not actually be that
simple just as raya probably glossed
over some less than shiny bits in her
account of history
the ending of riot and the last dragon
may not be quite as happily ever after
as it appears
it's implied that the droon are a part
of the world and that although the
people of camandra may drive off the
drone for a time
they're never truly gone they just go
dormant until a new opportunity arises
for them to strike for the dragons it
took
500 years until the five tribes could
come together and bring them back
hopefully it will take even longer for
them to fall apart enough for the drone
to find their way
back but adults will realize that as
rosy as the ending appears the threat of
the drone always remains
imagine this a group of gems each imbued
with immense magical power fall into the
wrong hands and as a result
vast numbers of people are
supernaturally wiped out in the blink of
an eye half a decade later a group of
survivors come together determined to
locate all the scattered gems and use
them to bring back all the people
they've lost
the effort involves some tricky heist
work but despite some bumps along the
road they're finally able to reassemble
all of the gems
ultimately through their teamwork and
the heroic sacrifice of their leader
they're able to reverse the dark magic
of the past and bring back
everyone they've lost sound familiar
obviously that's a broad summary of the
plot of raya and the last dragon but
it's also the basic storyline of 2019's
avengers end game
the massive climax to a decade's worth
of marvel cinematic universe adventures
obviously the two aren't exactly the
same but it's still hard to ignore the
parallels
kids may not notice some of the big
picture similarities but if their
parents are superhero fans they may get
a kick out of just how much overlap
there is
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one